clambering over stir needs Aloha is cos
makeshift bridge it's a journey made by
thousands day-in day-out this is the
only crossing point between government
and separatist-held territory for
hundreds of kilometers Nena Sidorenko
and her husband Anatoly live on the
separatist-held side but her pension and
the medicines she needs are only
available on government territory once a
month
Nena must cross the frontline each trip
is an ordeal scared the whole time on
the bridge I had to take a tranquilizer
what would have happened if someone had
tripped while they were carrying me but
since Ukraine's new president followed
Dima zalenski was elected Nina says she
at least feels hopeful Solinsky has
promised to make ending the war in
donbass his priority we were so
impatient just waiting for the election
we have such high hopes when Solinsky
gave his oath of office I simply cried I
just want all of this to end to finally
get back to peace
at least in stanitsa luganskaya that
could now be a little more likely even
though heavy artillery fire can still
occasionally be heard in the distance
block by block the Ukrainian Army is
dismantling its own forward defenses
this engagement means soldiers on both
sides are now several kilometers apart
where previously they could practically
look each other in the eye it's a
measure agreed on some two years ago but
it's only now being implemented under
Ukraine's new president we're showing
the new Ukrainian positions nothing is
supposed to give away its location the
soldier we meet is adamant this is no
retreat where we defend a [ __ ] crushing
the new position is bigger and better
first we could see the enemy better from
the bachata crush rotten akka 5 years of
conflict with the separatists have left
their mark more than 10,000 Ukrainians
have been killed and three times as many
injured since fighting broke out this
conflict has cost Natalia joy Benko
dearly back home in Luhansk she owned a
business that employed more than 150
people the separatists gave her just 6
hours to leave everything behind in
stanitsa luganskaya she began
volunteering coordinating donations for
the Ukrainian army she believes Ukraine
should not back down
Jannik I chose to wait I'm totally
against this withdrawal I don't want us
to give up this territory again this
must all stay Ukraine we need to join
the EU and NATO yeah with a neighbor
like Russia we can't live without NATO
this memorial is for the Ukrainian
soldiers who died in and around steny to
luhanska it was Natalia's idea given the
casualties Natalia says Ukraine must not
just cave in and accept peace at any
price
handsome that was his nickname he was a
scout I just seen him in the next
morning I got a call that he'd been shot
it happened nearby the last Monday in
the long
Nina Sidorenko has had enough she just
wants to get back to her old life a life
in peace Nina worked in a bakery and two
failed operation put her in a wheelchair
that was almost two decades ago her
pension is just 50 euros half of which
goes on nappies and drugs which she
can't get at home in separatist-held
territory it's time to head back to the
bridge
most people here will have to wait
several hours just to pass the
checkpoint in hot temperatures of 30
degrees Celsius fatalities are no rarity
in these queues another Union of
ordinary people have had enough of this
war we're grieving for the normal life
we used to live that's a cup on Mondays
reason you the scars left by five years
of war run deep but a little more
normality could perhaps finally be
around the corner president zalenski has
announced he intends to rebuild the
ruined bridge within weeks with or
without support from the separatist side